the safety net for trafficked children
is broken
and the price is that their abuse
continues often into adulthood
we've got to know one victim over the
course of nine months
Maria has been sexually abused by older
men from the age of 13 and now in her
early twenties is still abused sometimes
I'd be like gang raped by multiple men
at the same time
they pour petrol all over me whilst I
was like naked in that and then
threatened to burn me
Maria says for over a decade she's been
in the clutches of a dangerous gang who
using threat and intimidation sell her
for sex with that in mind we've met in
neutral locations away from her hometown
I was getting phone calls on Friday
saying that if I didn't come and meet
them they were going to burn down my
flat
and then put down my parents flat we've
seen the texts on her phone one reads
you know what's going to happen if you
don't do what we say kill you and your
fam another you're testing me today you
want a beating later it goes on to
describe brutal torture and videoing for
her family
so like the typical ones are will kill
you will get you will burn you will chop
you
and it sounds really stupid but they say
they'll sell me as Kebab meat in a
takeaway shop
she reported her abuse to the police and
although there have been no charges
against her abusers she was registered
as a victim of modern slavery on What's
called the national referral mechanism
when there was a big incident I asked to
go into a safe house and they were like
yeah that's fine
but nobody called me back
and I was later told by a member of
staff at the Salvation Army that we
don't like putting British victims into
safe houses and to contact the council
but I'd already why don't they like
putting British victims she didn't give
any reason at all
the Salvation Army is contracted by the
home office to support people on the
national referral mechanism and they say
when someone is referred to them as a
victim of modern slavery they see the
person's needs first and foremost they
add we can categorically state that we
never make decisions about what support
a person receives based on their
nationality if someone is in need of
Safe House accommodation regardless of
their circumstances or nationality they
will be found a suitable place
critics of the system say it was set up
principally for foreign Nationals
trafficked into the UK and professionals
sometimes failed to recognize British
victims who are being exploited within
the UK
but around a third of modern slavery
victims now being registered are British
and last year 70 of those in total 3 000
were children
once registered a potential victim gets
support for at least 45 days whilst
awaiting a conclusive decision on their
status but our investigation found that
that decision actually takes an average
of 553 days nearly one and a half years
the delays are getting worse and worse
and worse and worse and that is a huge
hindrance to the recovery of the
individuals in the nrm plus also it
massively increases the risk of
re-exploitation the sting in this story
is that during the course of the nine
months we've been in contact with Maria
she says she's been raped multiple times
and received further threats to set fire
to her home and although she's in
contact with the police she no longer
trusts them
every day I'm just kind of waiting for
something to happen
offer a phone call or for an incident
yeah
I'm just living in fear every day so
even if the call came through you know
now while we're doing this interview
and they said you've got to come tonight
you'd feel you had to go yeah
the home office has told us they are
working on improving decision making
times
it should be that the perpetrators live
life looking over their shoulders but
too often it's the victim living in fear
with no support Jason Farrell Sky News